- So the puzzle is why,
out of nowhere in
the last decade
have we seen a sudden and
sharp spike of teenage girls
who have no childhood and
history of gender dysphoria,
suddenly deciding they're trans
often with their girlfriends?
And the numbers
are quite alarming.
We now have, between
2016 and 2017,
the number of young women
asking for gender surgeries
quadrupled in United States.
(lighthearted music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and
this is The Rubin Report.
Joining me today for a
long overdue interview
is author of the new
book "Irreversible Damage
The Transgender Craze
Seducing Our Daughters".
Abigail Shrier, welcome
to The Rubin Report.
- Thanks so much
for having me on.
- So the book came out in June
and kind of caught fire in June.
And then I was gonna
have you on in August.
And I went off the grid
and then, you know,
there was election stuff
so I didn't have you on.
And then a couple of weeks ago,
all hell broke loose
because Target tweeted
that they were gonna no
longer carry the book.
So let's just start
with the controversy
because actually the reason
I'm having you on right now
is that after the controversy,
the book absolutely
sold out everywhere
and we had to hold
this interview
so that the book would
be stocked again.
So a lot's going on.
So let's just start with
the controversy first
because what you
write about here
in "The Transgender
Craze" is really like,
the hot topic of the day
and the thing that seems
to get the most people
in hot water.
So what happened with Target?
Let's start there.
- Sure, so look, you
know, we're living
through probably the biggest
medical scandal today
is that there's a sudden spike.
And these teenage
girls out of nowhere,
medically transitioning.
All of a sudden they want
hormones and surgeries
and they're easily
obtaining them.
And I wrote a book about it.
And because two Twitter users
decided the book
was transphobic,
they told that they
called it that to Target,
Target removed it.
And people were very upset.
You know, the book has a
lot of grassroots support.
A lot of parents feel
like it really explained
the story of what
happened to them
when they're teenagers
suddenly out of the blue,
decided with their friends
that they were transgender
and they were really upset.
And a lot of people
wrote to Target
and Target you
know, reinstated it.
It was one of the
few victories I think
against cancel culture.
- Yeah you must've
been pretty enthused
to see the amount of
support that you got.
Because yeah, you get
the usual Twitter haters
and the anonymous accounts
and all that stuff, you know,
pushing Target to a
decision like this.
But pretty much everybody
that still stands on
the side of free speech,
I guess we don't have
that many people anymore,
but pretty much
everyone that was around
supported you to
get this thing back.
And it actually did work.
- Yeah I was very gratified.
Look, you know, there are
literally hundreds of books
out there promoting,
unskeptically,
the immediate medical
transition of teenagers.
If you want to read that book,
there are hundreds
you could read.
And you know what?
I certainly would never call
for any of them to be banned
'cause I don't wanna live
in that kind of world.
But you know, there
is exactly one book
that did a deep dive
into this phenomenon
of teenage girls
suddenly transitioning
and it's my book.
And for the activists,
even one book is too many.
- Yeah okay, so let's start
with the most
important question.
Let's just get it out
there right from the top.
Abigail, are you a transphobe?
Do you have an irrational
fear of trans people?
And is that why you
wrote this book?
- No, I wrote the
book first of all
because a reader wrote to me
and she told me her daughter
had gone through
this phenomenon.
And when she, you know,
she said her daughter had
always been a girly girl,
never had gender dysphoria
this is a severe discomfort
in one's biological sex.
But when she got to high school,
she had a lot of
mental health issues.
And she went off to college
and with a group of girlfriends,
they all decided
they were transgender
and she started a
course of testosterone.
And I tried to find another
investigative journalist
who would take it up
because I had, you know,
I wasn't an
investigative journalist
and I couldn't find one.
So after four months I finally
got back in touch with her
and I said all right I'll do it.
I mean that's the
world we're living in.
And let me just say that a
lot of transgender adults,
and I interviewed a lot for
my book, support the book.
I mean the book does not,
I'm not against
medical transition.
It just urges caution when it
comes to these teenage girls.
- Okay so just to
be absolutely clear
and I know my audience
totally understands it.
But so you don't have a problem
with adults that transition,
that make the choice in
their lives to transition?
- No, I mean not only
am I not against it,
I've interviewed a lot
of transgender adults.
I believe it has
helped, it can help.
I know them, I've
talked to them.
And I'll tell you
something else,
I'm not even against all medical
transition for teenagers.
The only thing I
show in the book
is that the current
medical regime
has no medical
judgment in place.
It's totally based on the
judgment of teenagers.
And the doctors are told
to affirm, affirm, affirm,
meaning they have to agree
with the teenager's
self-diagnosis.
So there's no checks in place.
So the regime, the
current medical regime
is really not safe
for teenage girls.
- Yeah, so I was trying to think
how I wanted to
conduct this interview
because, you know, this
is one of the topics
that we've touched
on a bunch here.
Not because I particularly
care about these issues
as much as when it's become
such a hot button issue
then it sort of
gets to my plate.
But I thought,
I've read the book
and I thought that the
way that you laid it out
just even in the chapters,
the way you separated certain
things was really good.
So if you don't mind,
we'll just go through
chapter by chapter
and discuss each one.
So the introduction is
about the contagion.
And that's sort of
what you're hitting on
about what happened with your
friend's daughter at college.
Can you describe that?
- Sure so it's based on the
research of Lisa Littman
as we'll talk about
in the next chapter.
But the public health researcher
who looked into why
there was a sudden
and huge spike in teenage girls
who claimed to have
gender dysphoria.
And this is not the population
that traditionally had it,
it was always males.
And it usually began
in early childhood.
And all of a sudden across
the West, including America,
we have this sudden
spike of teenage girls
deciding they're transgender,
often with their friends
and often after
the encouragement
of social media influencers.
- Right so you talk about this
a little bit later in the book.
So I'm jumping ahead a bit.
But you tell a story of a girl
who in essence in high school
came out as transgender.
There weren't a lot of issues
that she was bringing
up before that,
but then suddenly she's
getting more likes on Tumblr.
She's now part of an
oppressed minority at school
and in different groups.
And that that allure basically,
and I know I'm getting a
little ahead of ourselves here,
but that allure, in a weird way,
is what's fueling
so much of this.
- That's right.
So it's young teenage girls.
These are often white, middle
or upper middle class girls.
They're very precocious
but they are high-anxiety
and high-depression girls.
They have a lot of
mental health issues.
And for the first time,
the moment they get to high
school or middle school
and decide they're
transgender, you know,
it's the first time they
get so much encouragement
and love, especially online.
And sometimes from adults.
And some of these adults are
not up to very much good.
But they get the showering
of love and praise
and they don't wanna
walk away from that.
- So chapter one which
is about the girls
that you're
describing right there
you know, we've
talked a lot about.
And I think you know I was
on tour with Jordan Peterson
for a year and a half.
And he focused more so I
would say on young men,
but it was a message
that obviously traversed,
it didn't matter what
gender you really were.
But is there something specific
going on with young girls
that we're not aware of?
Like there does seem to be an
emasculization of young boys
that we see.
But what do you think is
happening with young girls?
- Right, so teenage
girls specifically
fall for almost every one of
these so-called hysterias.
And the reason they do
is they tend to take
on their friend's pain.
If a young man is depressed,
very often his friend will say
okay let's go play basketball
or suggest doing something.
But he won't say,
what are you feeling?
Tell me about your pain.
And he won't start to
take it on himself.
He won't agree with his friend
about how terrible life is
just to make his
friend feel better.
But we know,
and I interviewed a lot of
psychologists about this,
young women tend to not only
take on their friend's pain
they're willing
to distort reality
in order to make their
friend feel better.
And so that's why they
tend to, you know,
all of these, you know,
anorexia is spread this way.
They tend to take on whatever
their friend's reality is.
Even if it's oh, I'm too fat.
Whatever they think will make
their friend feel better,
they'll take that on.
- Do you get pushback
when even you talk about
something sort of as simple
and kind of obvious?
Like we all know that is true,
men care more about things,
women care more about people.
Like these are things
that we all know.
But even saying
something like that,
do you find that
you get pushback
from the scientific
community on that?
That just boys and girls are
wired a little bit differently?
And of course there's
exceptions to the rule.
But as a general rule what
you just said is true.
- Right, so I do
get some pushback.
But actually I get
a lot of, you know,
I interviewed a lot
of people for the book
and a lot of scientific experts
and a lot of them agree.
I mean we know that you
can't house young women
who are anorexic on a
hospital wards together
without being really careful.
Because they will tend
to encourage each other
and their anorexia
will get more severe.
And it's, we don't...
It's not comparable with boys.
They don't go through
quite the same things.
- So chapter two is the puzzle.
Let's talk about the puzzle.
- So the puzzle is why,
out of nowhere in
the last decade,
have we seen a sudden and
sharp spike of teenage girls
who have no childhood and
history of gender dysphoria,
suddenly deciding they're trans
often with their girlfriends?
And the numbers
are quite alarming.
We now have, you know,
between 2016 and 2017
the number of young women
asking for gender surgeries
quadrupled in United States.
And we know it's
typically teenage girls
who are driving this population.
So the question is, why?
What is it about teenage girls?
Whenever you have any kind of
you know, diagnosis
that's exploding,
it really is
important to ask why.
And, you know, we're
not seeing this
with women in their 60s and 70s,
we're seeing the same population
that falls for every
other peer contagion.
- So what would you say the,
well you get to this
a little bit later,
but what would you say
is sort of the
answer to the puzzle?
I mean is it...
Or it's just a confluence
of many things,
education, social media
and everything, right?
- Right, and young women
who are in genuine
psychological pain
and these women are,
they tend to look to the culture
to help them understand it.
So in previous generations
they might've said,
oh, I'm so fat,
that's the problem.
If I just lose this
weight I'll feel better.
And today they look in
their culture and say,
oh, I know what this is.
I don't feel perfectly feminine.
I'm 13, I hate my body.
I must have gender dysphoria.
I'm supposed to be a boy.
- Yeah and that's one of
the hardest things there.
Because you have girls
that have legitimate issues
that they need to deal with
that adults should be
there to deal with them.
And yet they're being
prescribed the wrong thing.
- You might even say
that's the entire issue.
The entire issue is really,
and here's the problem,
it's not that transition
is never appropriate.
But we are living with this
affirmative care model now.
Which means that across
the West, doctors are told,
with this diagnosis, you
must agree with the patient,
no matter how young she is
or what are her other
mental health issues.
When she self-diagnoses
with gender dysphoria,
you agree with her.
And your next
question is basically,
when do we start the medication?
There's no oversight.
- Yeah, so it's an interesting
segue to the influencers,
which is the next chapter.
I'm really fascinated by this,
on how this stuff spreads.
- Yeah, so there are a lot
of social media influencers.
And for Gen Z, those
born in 1995 and after,
social media influencers
are as important,
if not more important
than Hollywood stars..
They really follow these
people, they look up to them.
And unfortunately there are
a lot of trans influencers
who are pedaling very,
very bad messages.
Like transition is easy.
Even if you don't
know if you're trans,
you should try a
course of testosterone
'cause that's the
only way to find out
if you're the real thing.
And they really downplay
the medical side effects
which are really severe
and irreversible.
- So what do you make of
the click part of this?
The people that are influencers
that keep talking
about this stuff,
even if they don't
understand the science,
even if they themselves
are not trans.
But that, for some reason,
there seems to be a tremendous
amount of just clicks.
I mean, literally just
clicks and eyeballs
that seem to drive this.
- Right, so one thing is,
you know I interviewed
influencers for my book.
And I do think some of them
really believe they're helping.
And one of the reasons they...
And they do genuinely feel
great about having transitioned.
And one of the reasons they do
is because testosterone
delivers a euphoria
and it suppresses anxiety,
which is some of these
girls' biggest problems.
So they go on it and they
think it's confirmation
that they got their
diagnosis right.
And they feel great
and they can't wait
to tell their friends.
The problem is we're
already seeing long-term,
you know, when you step out
of even just a few years,
there's tremendous
rates of regret,
and there's tremendous rates
of anxiety and depression.
It is not curing depression
in many instances.
And there really was no
medical oversight for it.
- Yeah and there's
really nothing
that can be done
about that, right?
I mean about the
influencers that,
for either good intentions
or bad intentions,
I mean, it is what it
is, we're all online.
- Yeah, I mean, you know,
getting some of these
young girls offline
is a good first step.
Look, when there was lots of,
I think they called it thinspo,
you know, the thinspiration on,
I think it was Instagram or one
of these social media sites,
they took it down
because inspiring girls
to anorexia was harmful.
But right now we have
trans influencers,
people who are suggesting
and encouraging
taking testosterone,
trying it out,
seeing how it feels
basically online.
And it's basically a Wild West.
They're never shut
down because, you know,
whenever someone says it's
a matter of civil rights
or a minority, everyone
stops thinking.
And certainly social media
doesn't police that at all.
- How long do they,
when people start taking,
or when these young girls
start taking testosterone,
how long does that bump that
you described there last,
where the anxiety
is gonna go down
and that sense of euphoria?
- I've talked to trans adults
who've said it lasted
their whole life.
In other words, they really
felt that in their case
that testosterone was
a really helpful drug.
And I'm fine with that.
The only problem, of course,
is that in the trans
adults I talked to,
they had to have certain
therapy to make sure.
And there was oversight
to make sure it was
the correct diagnosis.
Because right now,
teenage girls are deciding
this on their own.
And there isn't a
mental health oversight
in any meaningful way.
- Right, so we'll get more
to the medical part of
that in a little bit.
But so chapter five
is about the schools.
And I think this is
kind of fascinating
because we've sort of just
watched intellectual rot
run across all of our schools.
And you just have to kind of go
with whatever the
thing of the day is.
How much of this is just
sort of being taught
at public schools, do you think?
I know it depends
what state you're in,
but here we are both in Cali.
- So in California-
- For better or worse.
- Right, it's very
extreme in this state.
So gender identity education
is something you
can't opt out of.
It begins in kindergarten
and it's really extreme.
We start by teaching
five-year-olds that,
however they were born,
a doctor just made a guess
and only they know
their true gender.
And this doesn't push kids
to transition necessarily.
But what it does
do is the moment
these young girls in
particular hit adolescence,
they go through a period where
they hate their own bodies.
They feel ugly.
This is something nearly
every woman can attest to.
The solution readily
leaps to mind
because it's something they've
learned about for years.
And it's that, oh my gosh,
I know why I'm so
uncomfortable in my body.
It's 'cause I'm
supposed to be a boy.
- Were you able to
figure out at all,
how these bad ideas get so
influential at all the schools?
Seemingly all the schools,
at least in California.
But New York too, and
all over the country.
Just how infectious
the ideas are.
- Right, so I was, a little bit.
Because I was able to
get a lot of documents
out of the California
Teachers Association.
Concerned teachers
sent them to be,
uh, sent them to me.
And there's really no
division in California
between the activists
and the teachers.
Activists are not only
training the teachers,
they are providing
all the curriculum
for gender identity and
sexual orientation education.
So it's coming from
very extreme sources.
And in teachers who are a
little uncomfortable about it
are completely
intimidated into silence.
- So when you say that
at five years old,
they're taught this,
for the average parent
that might go into
that school and say,
well, I don't want my child
hearing that at five years old.
Which no five-year-old,
it has nothing to do with
even what's true or not,
no five-year-old can
comprehend this stuff.
In effect, that person
is gonna be blacklisted
and God only knows what
they'll do to the poor kid.
- That's right, you can't.
Because in California, they
did something really sneaky.
They put this curriculum into
the anti-bullying curriculum.
So usually you would think
this would go into
the sex ed curriculum,
which parents are
allowed to opt out of.
But they put it into the
anti-bullying curriculum
under the pretext
that you couldn't
possibly police bullying
unless you taught every child
that only they know
their true gender.
And of course we
know that's nonsense
because you can
absolutely police bullying
and should police bullying
against sexual minorities
and every other student,
without introducing everybody
to a false ideology.
- Yeah, do you have any numbers
on what percentage of the
public school teachers
actually buy it verse
who's just going along?
I guess that would
be hard to quantify.
- It's very hard.
Public school teachers
are terrified.
I spoke to one teacher
who posted something
on social media.
It was very tamed.
She said, I don't know,
this seems to be confusing
a lot of kids at my
school, effectively.
And she was suspended
immediately.
And this was on her
private Facebook page.
So teachers are
very, very afraid.
- Yeah, so the next chapter
is the moms and dads which,
speaking of very, very afraid,
it seems like a lot of
the moms and dads are too.
- Yeah, they're afraid.
They're afraid to lose custody.
And these are, you know,
the parents who call me
are overwhelmingly
political progressives.
They are proud allies.
They've always been allies.
But their only sort of
hesitation in this problem
is they think, gosh,
this came out of nowhere.
I mean, I supported
her when she said
that she was a lesbian,
but now she's saying she's a boy
and she wants to have
her breasts removed?
I mean, I'm not sure
that's right for her.
And is it, couldn't
she regret it?
These are the most sort
of obvious questions.
There's nothing hateful
about these questions.
But today these parents
are treated like bigots.
They're isolated, their
friends drop them.
And very often friends
will go behind their backs
to send their
daughters encouragement
by way of a binder, the one
of those compression garments
or otherwise castigate them
for bigotry, allegedly.
- What did this
teach you, maybe,
or you're a parent yourself,
I mean, did this
teach you anything
about parenting in general
and setting rules and being
honest and the rest of it?
- Sure, I think one
thing it taught me
was really how much we've
over relied on experts.
These so-called
experts who show up
and claim to know more
than we do about our kids
that we have spent,
I don't know,
hundreds of thousands
of hours raising.
And I think that trusting
your own instincts
about what's right for your
daughter, I mean, if you...
In many cases,
parents will call me
and it just doesn't
sit right with them.
But they are being pressured
by the mental health
establishment or doctors
to immediately agree
with their daughter
and fast track her to
irreversible consequences
that she's likely to regret.
- So since you said the
P word, progressives,
do you sense that
there is a connection
between sort of being
politically progressive
and that he would end up
in a situation like this?
That you sort of just,
yes, everything
goes all the time.
There is nothing that's
really true per se,
and everything is
sort of how you feel.
That this was the obvious
outcome of it in a weird way.
- Well, I think my take is that
the reason so many
progressive families
have fallen into this,
and let me say conservative
families have as well,
but the reason it
does seem to me,
majority progressive families,
is because they were less
skeptical of the culture.
Conservatives have
known for a long time
that a social worker
or a psychologist
might not treat their
values with respect.
But liberals who are
genuinely taken aback
and completely caught off-guard
because they thought,
wait a second,
I've been an ally
my entire life.
This isn't about that.
It's about the mental
health of my daughter.
She's got anxiety, depression.
Shouldn't we look at
those things first?
And they were really
assuming good faith
on behalf of, you know, frankly
activists posing as doctors.
- Yeah, and we've just...
It seems to me that
that, unfortunately,
for a lot of the liberals,
and I think you know a little
bit about my story, you know,
for a lot of liberals, until
something like this hits them,
they think that there's
nothing wrong there.
That it's just like,
oh, anything goes.
And then next thing you know,
they're confronted with this
and then they feel a
little bit differently.
- That's right,
they describe themselves
now, overwhelmingly,
as politically homeless.
And it's not because
they feel conservative.
It's because they
are really horrified
by the assault on
their families.
I mean, that all of these these
mental health professionals
and teachers would
go behind their backs
to encourage their
children to do something
that they think
is harmful to them
is so stunning to them.
And it does make them
really uncomfortable
with progressive politics.
- Yeah, so did you have a sense,
or do you have a sense
that conservative parents
have some better
mechanisms to fight this?
Either by standing
up to the school
or maybe dealing with the
child a little bit differently
or whatever it might be?
- Yeah, it's interesting.
I think conservative
parents were, tended to be,
and should be more
skeptical of the culture.
They were more skeptical
of these social workers
and psychologists
who claim to know so
much about their parents.
But they also...
Look their default is that,
what do you mean
you're suddenly a boy?
See sometimes progressive
parents were afraid to say that
because they don't
wanna be bigoted.
But a conservative parent
might be more comfortable
just saying, what do you mean?
You've been a girl your
whole life, you're a girl.
I mean, just because you
want a short haircut,
doesn't suddenly make you a boy.
- Yeah are you worried that
the slippery slope of this
ultimately is that, you know,
a girl, a young girl
will basically announced
that she's trans at school.
A parent or the
parents will say,
well, we're not transitioning
you something like that.
And then as the state grows,
and again, we're
both in California,
that literally the state
will start taking kids
away from their parents.
Is that something that
you think is really legit?
- It's already happening.
I mean, you especially
hear that now
where with divorced couples
where they're not
on the same page.
I've been called by
a mother who was,
you know, she was divorced,
but she had full
custody of the daughter
because the court deemed her
the more responsible,
better parent.
And when the daughter hit 13,
out of nowhere, she
decided she was trans
with the encouragement of her
therapist and her stepmom.
And the moment the mom put
the brakes on it and said,
honey, you don't,
look, you know?
And the mom was not
gender-conforming herself.
The mom said, honey,
look, you're still a girl.
Just because you don't wanna
dress girly, that's fine.
Then a social worker
was brought in
and decided that the mom
was no longer a safe parent.
- God, I mean it's
just, it's twisted.
It's deeply twisted.
What about on the parent's side
where we've seen some
stories like this.
I can think of one from
about two months ago.
Where it really seems to be
the parent that's driving this.
That the stuff we talked
about earlier about,
oh, you suddenly are getting
a lot of likes on Tumblr,
or you're feeling like
you're in a group suddenly.
But we've heard some instances
where it seems like the parents
are the ones driving their
children towards this.
Because then they sort of by
proxy, feel popular or liked,
or they're an
oppressed-group-adjacent
or something.
- Right, so I think
that does happen.
The population I really looked
at is the biggest population.
It's this teen girl population.
And there, you don't...
You know these are young women
who aren't listening
to mom at all.
In fact, the last thing
they want is advice for mom.
And so usually in that instance,
the parents aren't
so much the driver.
Sometimes with the little kids,
you do see parents who seem to
be pushing this awfully hard
and certainly seem to be
bragging about it online
in ways that make you wonder
if they aren't getting
something else out of it.
- Yeah, all right, the
shrinks are up next.
I know that you're not thrilled
with the way therapists
have dealt with this.
- Yeah, I mean they have an
affirmative model right now,
the majority.
Although I interviewed, look,
I interviewed a lot
of giants in the field
who don't agree with it and
are not affirmative therapists.
But affirmative therapy says
we start from the conclusion.
We know that we're
gonna agree with
that a young person who says
they're gender dysphoric,
we're gonna agree that
that's the right diagnosis.
We'll affirm them
as transgender.
And the only question is,
when do we get started
on the medications?
And that's just not medicine.
Medicine is an evaluation
of risks and benefits.
And the moment you are open
about the risks and benefits
of any medical treatment,
you're not in the gender
affirmative camp anymore,
you're on my side of things.
Which is to have an open look
and approach with
some skepticism,
how these girls are and
whether they're benefiting.
- So do you sense
that some of the psychologists
or the psychiatrists
that they're actually not
telling these young girls
what the numbers
are in terms of,
either regretting
it later in life
or that it's not gonna
solve all of your problems?
Or that suicides are still high?
I mean, all of these things
that are uncomfortable
to talk about.
I mean, do you sense that
they kind of hide that,
because they're just on board?
- Well, remember that we have
20 conversion therapy laws
that prohibit them from doing
anything other than affirming,
because that might be considered
the so-called
conversion therapy.
It might be trying to convert
them out of being trans.
- So in essence, they
can lose their license?
- They could lose their license.
Now of course,
conversion therapy,
the reason we passed these bands
was to eliminate the
really ugly practices
of gay conversion therapy.
That's how they got passed.
But they inserted,
activists inserted
gender identity language.
So now a therapist can't
even say to a child,
hold on, I know you
say you're a boy,
but let's explore some
of the other things
that seem to be upsetting you.
- Yeah, can you clean
that up a little bit
for people that have no
knowledge of any of this?
The sort of difference
between sexual identity,
meaning your sexuality
verse gender identity.
And why conversion in each case,
or conversion therapy
in these cases,
is not exactly apples to apples?
- Sure, so with homosexuality,
you know, we've long known
that this is seems to
be innate and immutable.
It's not the kind
of thing you can
sort of convert someone out
of or convince them out of.
And nor should you want to.
I mean, there's nothing
unhealthy about a gay life.
There just isn't.
But when you're talking about
you know, letting a
child be uncomfortable
in their own body.
Because gender identity, if
a young woman suddenly says,
I'm really a boy, I
need to become a boy,
you're setting them up to be
a lifetime medical patient
where they will put
testosterone in their bodies.
They need to stay
on it for life.
It has all kinds of terribly
extreme side effects.
They're highly risky.
And unlike, you know, therapy
that may make her
comfortable in her body,
the today's therapy
pushes her to transition.
That's very different
from being gay
in which all the gay person asks
is that you accept
them for what they are.
What a trans teen asks is,
can you help me try
to be what I'm not?
And that's a much more
invasive intervention.
- Yeah, you know, I'm reminded
as you're talking about this,
I'm blanking on whether you
mentioned this show in the book.
Did you talk about
"Transparent" at all the show?
- No, I didn't.
- So there's a line in the last
episode of the first season
where a woman who's
already transitioned
says to the main character who's
about to begin the process,
in effect, this is
gonna ruin your life.
This is gonna ruin your family.
And that, in many ways,
is what the show
ended up being about.
And I know that's not about
a child transitioning,
but I think a lot of
what you're talking about
is just that so many people
just don't have a holistic view
of what this is going to
be like on the other side.
- That's exactly right.
And when I interviewed
transgender adults
who are very happy in their
transitions very often,
they will still tell me,
look, this is not easy.
It's not easy to go through life
on all this hormonal treatment.
You know, holding yourself out
as a member of the opposite sex,
it's really hard.
And when transgender
adults talk to me about it,
they are horrified
that teenagers
are getting this hormonal
treatments so easily,
without any kind of
understanding of the risks,
and not appreciating how hard
medical transition really is.
- So all that being said,
chapter seven is
about the dissidents.
There are some
dissidents in the field.
- That's right.
A number of prominent people
have stood out and said,
hold on, this is way too much,
way too fast with too
little medical oversight.
You know, look,
the court found...
And I interviewed a lot of them,
including Ken Zucker
who chaired the entry,
the writing of the entry
on gender dysphoria
for the DSM-5, the
classic psychiatric manual
on mental disorders.
And these are people who say,
starting with the conclusion
is not medicine, right?
And in fact, last week,
the British high court
examined the same protocols
that they have in place in
Britain for gender medicine.
And the high court was appalled.
They said, in effect,
what's been going on here
is likely to transition
a lot of young women
who are not supposed
to be transgender.
And a lot of young people
who are likely to
experience severe regret.
- So are you surprised,
I guess this is the right
chapter to ask you about this,
are you surprised how this thing
so part of the culture war.
That it's not just,
okay, this is happening
to young girls at school,
that's one portion of it,
but this is becoming something
that Joe Biden is tweeting
about transgender
violence all the time.
And Kamala's saying,
or Elizabeth Warren,
I think Kamala
said it too about,
black transgender women are
the backbone of the economy.
I mean, like really crazy stuff
that no one's against
transgender people.
But just how this has become
such a part of the zeitgeists.
Like, this is like
a bellwether thing
where you either accept
it or you're a dissident,
you're a bad guy.
- Yeah, it really has.
You know, it's so interesting,
when I first wrote a
proposal for my agent,
it was actually gonna be
on a contemporary
book about feminism.
I had written one article
about this whole sudden spike
in teenage girls
identifying as trans thing.
But it certainly wasn't
a passion of mine
and I wasn't intending
to turn it into a book.
And my agent said to me,
listen, that article you wrote
seems to have gotten
a lot of attention.
And frankly, if what
you're really interested in
is how young women
today are doing,
it seems to be a really
good way to explore
all the other issues
you're interested in
like free speech and how
young women are fairing today.
So it did end up being
sort of incredible lens
for looking at so many
aspects of the culture.
So I guess that's
why it seems to be
at the nexus of a lot
of different things.
- Yeah, well, that's why
it's so fascinating to me
because over the years I've
interviewed a lot of people
who suddenly find themselves
in the thick of the battle
without really wanting in on it.
They were just sort of
interested in something else.
And next thing, you know,
the battle comes to them.
And even though I
hadn't, you know,
this is the first time
that we're actually
speaking one-on-one,
when I saw the Target
thing, I was like,
I'm gonna go out on a limb
and guess that Abigail is
probably not that combative,
probably didn't really want
all of this extra attention
and everything else.
So what has it been like
for you to be a dissident
in something that is
so hard to talk about?
- You know, I wouldn't have
written this book, kind of,
if I didn't think a few things,
if I didn't think what
was going on today
is kind of madness.
I do believe we're gonna look
back on this time and say,
what were we doing?
I mean, why were we letting
very upset teenagers
in a lot of pain
immediately
medically transition,
and risk there fertility and
future sexual dysfunction?
So I think that's what
the high court in England
just looked at last week.
It was a major case.
Of course the media in the
U.S. tried to ignore it
and mostly did.
But it was a huge case,
this is a neutral tribunal.
And they looked at the
exact same protocols
we have in place today
and they were horrified.
They basically
said, why aren't...
You know, these young kids can't
give informed consent at 15
to eliminating their
future fertility.
What are we doing?
- Yeah, but what about
for you personally,
just like going through the
headaches of all of this.
And you were on Joe Rogan
and then the Spotify people,
you know, some
employees at Spotify
basically wanted to
kick him off Spotify.
Fortunately, that didn't happen.
Everyone heard what
happened with Target,
but you're back into Target.
I mean, just for you personally,
as someone that, you
know, you're now out there
and you live in L.A.,
I mean, you're here
in this weird town, you know?
Just the personal cost.
- You know what's funny?
When I wrote the book,
I actually worried that it
would be completely ignored.
(laughing)
- Little did you know.
- I was surprised a little bit.
But I had seen...
I wasn't completely surprised
and I'll tell you why.
Because I had watched every
scientist who has ever,
and many of them I
interviewed in the book,
who has ever come out
against affirmative therapy,
who has ever come out and said,
hold on, what's going on?
Does seems to have a
lot of peer influence.
Or have said, this isn't real
therapy, there's no oversight.
Every scientist who's done
that has been canceled.
And sometimes they've
lost their jobs.
And very often they've been
really caught off guard
by the vitriol and
the, frankly, bad faith
on the opposite side.
So I at least had the
benefit of their example.
And I was a little bit
more prepared for that.
- Right, has it cost you, do
you think, professionally?
I mean, the book is
obviously doing well now.
But do you think this
will ultimately close
some other doors
that you may not
even know about?
- I'm sure, I mean you
know, it's a question...
I do believe that we're
gonna look back on this age.
I mean look, you
know, in England
where they have the exact
same medical protocols
and the exact same spike
among adolescent girls
'cause they have the
same social media we do,
The Economist and
The Times of London
both just named my book to a
best books list for the year.
So even though the legacy
media in the United States
completely ignored my book,
in England, their media seems
to have found it worthwhile.
So, you know, I'm hoping
the sanity at some
point prevails.
- Yeah, you know, I'm wondering,
I wonder if there's
any numbers on this.
I'm sure someone
could figure it out.
But I find whenever
I just suddenly get
like 1000 hate tweets in a row,
almost every single one of them,
if I look at the bio of
the people that send it,
has gender pronouns in there.
And I always think it's so
interesting that, you know,
the people that I suppose
purport to be the most tolerant,
the most diverse, the most open,
that they're the ones that are
often sending the most anger.
So I can only imagine
what you are opening up
your Twitter to find.
- From the tolerant people.
- (laughs) Yeah, you can imagine
the sort of threats I get.
But I would just
say that, you know,
look, I know a
lot of transgender
adults at this point.
And then I try to say
this in every interview
because it's really true.
The crazy woke activists
do not speak for them.
They don't represent
these crazies.
And they are not represented
by these crazies.
And I have to say,
transgender people I've met
are some of the
loveliest most sober
and really insightful
people I've gotten to know.
So these woke activists,
they are the same people
leading black lives matter
and every other
extreme group today.
And they don't represent
transgender people.
Certainly the ones I've-
- Actually, I kind of
want it to get there.
Can you talk a little bit
about the intersectional
nature of this?
How it went from
black lives matter
to sort of black
trans lives matter.
That these things all
do sort of link together
in the woke mind?
- Yeah, it's very similar.
I mean, it's an extreme ideology
which judges everybody
according to their rank.
And their rank is based on
these so-called victim classes.
And the woke trans
activists are the same way.
The moment you declare
you're a trans,
you rise in their
intersectional pyramid.
And the problem with that is
a lot of lonely teenage...
I mean, there are a lot
of problems with it,
but one of them is that a
lot of lonely teenage girls
who are white girls,
they're members of the
oppressive majority, right?
As soon as they choose
a trans identity,
they finally get released.
They get a shield
from all the hate
they're getting
from their peers.
- God, it's so pervasive.
It's just unbelievable.
You know, you mentioned some
of the adult trans people
that you talk to,
and obviously how great
they can be in society
and happy and everything else.
You mentioned Deirdre
McCloskey in the book
who I've had on the show,
who's one of our
great economists.
And I wonder when you
talk to any of them,
when they talk
about transitioning,
does anyone say that
they actually...
You know and she,
Deirdre is probably
in her 60s or 70s I suppose.
Do any of them say, oh, I
wish I had done it earlier?
- That's interesting.
Not usually.
And I'll tell you why.
Because they really believe,
even though they obviously wish
that they could
pass more easily.
Certainly that the male to
female on a transgender adult,
often wish they could
pass more easily
and they struggled to pass.
They also often will tell you
that the process they
went through in therapy
before they were allowed
to immediately transition,
they felt that that process
was a really good process
to make sure they were right
and that it wasn't
some other impulse
or other mental
health issue at play.
So the thing that's crazy right
now about the discussion is,
the activists insist,
we have to transition
these kids immediately
because otherwise they'll
regret it later in life.
Well, it's mostly biological
men who worry about that.
And yet they're making the case
that that should apply
to teenage girls.
I mean, teenage girls
who put this testosterone
in their bodies tend
to 40 times the amount
their bodies would
normally handle.
They actually
transition pretty well.
You know, they get full beards.
They get male pattern baldness.
Their voices change.
Their physique changes.
They don't have quite
the same barriers
that men have when they
transition to women.
- Yeah, you know,
you just mentioned
the passing portion of this.
Meaning that you can
transition from one sex or...
And be thought of just sort
of generally as that sex.
So it's easier, in
essence, you're saying,
for younger girls to
transition to boys
and be thought of as boys,
as opposed to the
other way around,
and you think that
probably makes the decision
a little bit easier?
- Well, this is what I'll say.
It's not that it's
easy, 'cause it's not.
I mean, they will
always be smaller.
They'll need a
double mastectomy.
It's not an easy road,
And they end up very
often needing hysterectomy
as in all these
followup surgeries,
they're actually
quite uncomfortable
and have serious repercussions.
It's not that it's easy,
it's that the men, biological
men are making the argument
that I wish I could
pass better as a woman.
So we need to transition
these kids earlier.
But there are no...
You know, because they
maybe have stubble
or they don't have a jaw
that looks like a woman's.
But the case is less
obviously made for a woman
who transitioned to a man.
Because other than being,
she'll be smaller ultimately
than a biological male.
But, you know, look,
I know trans men
who are very convincing.
And more convincing
than, you know,
some of the trans
women that I know.
- Right, what do
you make of the idea
that some of this is
actually bizarrely anti-gay?
Because people seem to
think that these letters
all have something to
do with each other.
But I've sort of come
around to this idea
that if you, you
know, we hear this,
that if you have
an effeminate boy,
so a five or seven-year
old that is effeminate,
who probably is just a gay boy,
who'll grow up to be a gay man,
that a lot of these parents,
instead of having to
deal with the realities
of having a gay son,
that in a weird sense,
it's almost like,
oh, it would actually be
easier if he was just a girl,
He behaves like a girl.
And that that, in and of
itself, is oddly anti-gay.
- Yeah, I do think there's
an element of that.
There's an element
of that homophobia.
You see it sometimes because
the parents will see...
And part of it is
not necessarily
homophobia, I should say.
Part of this discomfort
of, you know,
I have this child
who seems to be
like they might end up gay.
I have to do
something immediately.
But parents feel like they
have to immediately intervene
and do something.
And they feel this way
about almost everything
about their kids' lives.
That's why they're called
helicopter parents, right?
And then sometimes the answer
is really just to leave them be.
There's nothing, okay?
They may emerge as
gay, they may not,
I guess time will tell.
But that doesn't mean
you have to do something.
And unfortunately, in
this age, we don't wait.
The answer is always start a
course of medication right now.
And I do think that's played in.
- Did you meet a lot of,
I guess, well your research
obviously was about girls
that were transitioning to boys,
but did you meet or have
you talked to people
that have focused on that idea
of these sort of feminine
boys who then transitioned.
And then years later
they just realize,
oh, I was just a
feminine gay boy.
- I actually don't
know about that
as a larger
phenomenon, you know?
This is a really
recent phenomenon.
This epidemic is in
the last 10 years,
and it really has been
driven by teen girls.
So with boys, it's
harder to track.
Because there have always
been some percentage of boys
who naturally would end up
as what we used to
call transsexuals.
So it's harder to
say in their case,
oh, that's certainly peer
contagion or homophobia
or anything else in play.
But with the girls, we
know this population
never experienced gender
dysphoria in any numbers
that were at all significant.
And in fact, there's
no extant literature
on teen girls transitioning
who didn't have childhood
gender dysphoria at all.
So it's a clear
case with the girls.
- Yeah, all right, let's
move to chapter eight,
the promoted and the demoted.
We sort of hit on
this a little bit.
- Sure, so I think
one of the things
sort of at play with all of this
is that women have
really fallen in esteem
in the broader culture.
Certainly vis-a-vis
trans people.
And we see this all the time
where young girls
are asked to...
You know, womanhood is
denigrated in many ways.
One of the ways is through porn.
Young kids are seeing porn,
and very violent porn
at very young ages
on the internet now,
it's widely available.
It's quite violent.
And being a woman doesn't
seem so great to them.
And then you see
that biological boys
are able to out-compete
them in sports.
No one stands up for them.
I think it's pretty clear
that in the competition
between girls and trans youth
in terms of esteem in
the broader culture,
girls have fallen.
And I do think girls
are feeling that.
- Yeah, so who were the
promoted then within that?
- Oh, so I think that
being transgender today
has sort of written
risen in esteem.
And look, I think it's good
that a lot of these
taboos have fallen away.
I certainly would never want
transgender people to
be at all mistreated
or not have full rights
or the same wonderful,
open treatment
that anyone should
be able to get.
So the only question is
are girls rushing to transition
for the right reasons?
- Yeah, so chapter nine is
about the transition actually.
And I think for this topic,
it's like a lot of people
know nothing about this
and in a weird way,
don't really have to
know anything about it.
But what should people know
about chapter nine and
the transformation itself?
- Sure, I would just
say that transition,
gender transition is
always an uphill battle.
It's really hard, you know?
I interviewed even
forensic anthropologists
who talked about
the bone structure,
taught me about
the bone structure
that's so different
between males and females.
Including even the skull,
the way the forehead
slopes is different.
And the point of this is just
that transition's very hard.
Medical transition is very hard.
It requires constant
medicalization.
It comes with severe risks.
Young women are at risk,
not only of
infertility, you know?
Depending on when they
start, sexual dysfunction
and all kinds of, you
know, endometrial cancer,
all kinds of things.
But that it's, you know,
this is not a decision
to be taken lightly.
And unfortunately, today
it's taken so lightly
that the biggest risk
of all is regret.
- Yeah, so that's a
perfect transition
to chapter 11, the way back.
- Right, so one of the
things I say in the book
is that I do think a few things.
Young women today
have to be told
that being a woman
is a great thing.
That being uncomfortable
in your body during puberty
is completely normal.
And whatever kind
of girl you are,
you know, same-sex
attracted, heterosexual,
whatever kind of girl you are
is a perfectly great
kind of girl to be.
And being a woman actually
is way more wonderful
and comes with a lot
more pleasures and joys
than the current culture admits.
- Yeah, and that's just
something that culture...
I mean, again, this sort
of gets back to the family
and culture and education
and everything else, right?
There's not one culprit here.
- Yeah, I think that's right.
There are a lot of forces
trying to say that being
a woman is terrible today,
it's a victim class.
A lot of feminists have
decided it's a victim class.
I mean, looking at the way
lesbians are treated today.
Their bars are disappearing.
They are harassed.
A lot of lesbians have told
me that their social groups
have had to go online because
they are so often harassed
by transgender adults
who claim to be lesbians
and come on to them sexually.
You know, this is a very...
It's tough to be a woman
today and in certain sense.
And we've lost...
And not a lot of women are
standing up for women's rights
and the rights of girls
to be whatever kind
of girl they wanna be.
- You know, it's so fascinating
'cause if you would have said
what you just said
there, four years ago,
look what's happening to
lesbians being harassed,
blah, blah, blah.
If you would've said
that four years ago,
people would have thought,
oh, she means that
people on the right
or Christian
conservatives or something
are coming after lesbians.
And it's simply, well, it
barely exists at this point,
at least in an American context.
But what you're talking about
is being bullied by the
trans people and saying,
if you're not attracted to me
now that I've transitioned
or something else,
now you're a transphobe.
And that's really fascinating
how quickly that has all shifted
- Yeah, and it's the activist.
Look, I can't tell you,
I've interviewed a
lot of trans women
who would be horrified to make
other women uncomfortable,
make women uncomfortable.
They would never harass women.
But unfortunately this activist
group is taking advantage.
I mean, you know,
you see this all over
in so many ways.
Smith College, which
was always all-women
now admits biological boys.
You know, lesbians
who try to have
their own social groups or bars,
they're constantly harassed
by biological men who
claim to be women.
And are forcing their way in.
Battered women's
shelters, the same thing.
Prisons in California.
If you say you're a woman,
you get housed with
the women prisoners.
And this is obviously
very dangerous.
Not because transgender people
are dangerous, of course,
but because biological
men pose dangers
living in close quarters of
prison with biological women.
- Yeah, which by the way, not
to get too political on you,
but Joe Biden even said,
you should be allowed to choose
what prison you wanna go to
based on your gender identity.
I mean this is-
- Yeah, I mean, look,
I happen to think that,
housing a biological woman
with a biological man in prison
has got to be cruel
and unusual punishment.
And yet we're seeing men
who are even found guilty
of sexual violence,
you know, sexual assault,
housed with female prisoners.
It's really unconscionable.
- Yeah, so you do an
afterword in the book
called the update.
So what is the update?
Where are we at right now?
- (laughs) Well,
look, I think people
are waking up to this issue.
They're seeing that there's
very often peer influence.
This is not organic.
But right now,
because this is being pumped
through the school systems,
because kids are seeing
so much of, you know,
getting so much encouragement
from social media,
we are seeing this
younger and younger.
You know, young teens suddenly
deciding they're trans.
And I would just say,
parents, if your
kid, out of nowhere,
decides they're transgender
and their peer groups doing
the same thing and whatnot,
just be aware that there's
very often peer influence
or social media
influence at play.
- Yeah, well listen Abigail,
thanks for taking the time.
I'm sorry it took so long.
And I know our social circles
have been getting
closer and closer.
So hopefully when we're free
citizens here in Los Angeles,
we can do this over
a meal or something.
And we're gonna put a link-
- I would love that.
- Obviously to the
book down below.
Hopefully it'll be back in
stock by the time we put it up.
But who knows? We'll see.
- Hope so.
- Right now as we take this,
it's completely sold
out everywhere, right?
- That's right.
But they're getting them
back into stores, I'm told.
So hopefully(laughs).
- All right, well thanks
for taking the time.
I appreciate it.
- Thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about women's issues
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our women's
issues playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.